Tasha: 哎呀我已经叉掉了
Tasha: Oh no, I already crossed it out.
Jake: 没关系没问题
Jake: It's okay, no problem.
Jake: 再再来了
Jake: Let's try again.
Jake: 硕
Jake: Shure.
Shure: 哎哎哎
Shure: Hey, hey, hey.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Katrina:  你那个甜品展架啥的买了吗
Katrina: Did you buy the dessert display stand?
Tasha: 买了
Tasha: Yes, I did.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Jake: 啊这个可以
Jake: Ah, this is good.
Tasha: 哎他这个居然没有停止他的进度哎
Tasha: Hey, it surprisingly didn't stop its progress.
Jake: OK可以
Jake: OK, it's fine.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Alright.
Jake: 呃我们先收拾收拾去吧
Jake: Uh, let's tidy up first.
Shure: 一想到刚刚所有人都在外面
Shure: Thinking about everyone being outside just now,
Shure: 然后在里面洗澡
Shure: and then taking a bath inside,
Shure: 好，好羞耻
Shure: it's so embarrassing.
Katrina:  害怕不
Katrina: Scared?
Katrina:  害怕我们进去吗
Katrina: Scared we'll go in?
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 还好你没洗碗
Tasha: Good thing you didn't wash the dishes.
Alice: 不是我一般晚上洗
Alice: I usually wash them at night.
Jake: 那那你你先画我们先上去
Jake: Then you draw first, we'll go up.
Katrina:  我马上就来
Katrina: I'll be there soon.
Jake: 走我们上去收拾收拾
Jake: Let's go upstairs and tidy up.
Tasha: 你要在楼上洗碗吗
Tasha: Are you washing dishes upstairs?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha: 是在楼上洗碗吗
Tasha: Are we washing dishes upstairs?
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  我们要洗碗
Shure: We have to wash dishes?
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Jake: 洗了吗
Jake: Did you wash them?
Shure: 没洗呢
Shure: Not yet.
Tasha: 带这个厨房湿巾就行了
Tasha: Just bring these kitchen wipes.
Jake: 出来拧拧眼镜
Jake: Come out and clean your glasses.
Jake: 随时不着急
Jake: Anytime, no rush.
Jake: 我们先把这个收拾收拾
Jake: Let's tidy this up first.
Jake: 然后再把呃房间每人秀一下
Jake: Then everyone can show their rooms.
Jake: 我去
Jake: I'm going.
Jake: 无从下手
Jake: No idea where to start.
Tasha: 怎么这么厚的感觉
Tasha: Why does it feel so thick?
Lucia: 他就是很厚但是一直没找到地方放
Lucia: It's just really thick, but we haven't found a place to put it.
Lucia: 是前两天比较凉的时候穿的
Lucia: It was worn when it was cooler a few days ago.
Alice: 啊直接倒进去吗
Alice: Ah, just pour it in directly?
Tasha: 我靠你这手
Tasha: Whoa, your hand!
Jake: 嗯我去我这手
Jake: Yeah, my hand, geez.
Tasha: 嗯来
Tasha: Yeah, come on.
Alice: 直接倒进去
Alice: Pour it directly.
Alice:不会把下水下水道给堵了吗
Alice: Won't it clog the drain?
Tasha: 他不是有网吗
Tasha: Doesn't it have a mesh?
Tasha: 我在当时想
Tasha: I was thinking at the time.
Alice:就这个油一凝固他不就
Alice: Once the oil solidifies, won't it...
Tasha: 所以尽快让他溶下去吗
Tasha: So we need to make it dissolve quickly, right?
Tasha: 没关系我们后面不用这个池子
Tasha: It's okay, we don't need this sink later.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:乾坤
Alice: Universe.
Jake: 得得这样是吧
Jake: Like this, right?
Jake: 这样有用吗
Jake: Does this work?
Tasha: 有用
Tasha: It works.
Alice: 没关系随便吧
Alice: Doesn't matter, just go ahead.
Tasha: 有用
Tasha: It works.
Alice: 好玩吗
Alice: Is it fun?
Jake:我也不想玩
Jake: I don't want to play either.
Jake: 说实话
Jake: To be honest.
Tasha: 我们要打扫干净才能离开这个民宿
Tasha: We need to clean up thoroughly before we leave this guesthouse.
Tasha: 对吗
Tasha: Right?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 我现在擦也没啥用
Jake: Wiping it now won't help much.
Tasha: 擦呀
Tasha: Wipe it!
Tasha: 这这这里面不是有
Tasha: Isn't there...
Tasha: 洗洁精吗
Tasha: Dishwashing liquid in here?
Alice: 这个油比较多嘛
Alice: There's a lot of oil, though.
Jake:先先先先洗这个是吧
Jake: So, wash this first, right?
Jake: 先洗哪个呀
Jake: Which one do I wash first?
Tasha: 那你就先洗锅吧
Tasha: Then just wash the pot first.
Jake: 好那这个我我扔
Jake: Okay, so I'll throw this...
Jake: 我扔哪了
Jake: Where do I throw this?
Tasha: 哪个
Tasha: Which one?
Jake:里面的东西
Jake: The stuff inside.
Alice: 这个垃圾桶呢
Alice: What about this trash can?
Jake: 给个袋子吧
Jake: Give me a bag.
Jake: 来来袋子袋子上袋子
Jake: Come on, come on, a bag, we need a bag.
Alice: 是不是在那啥
Alice: Is it over there?
Tasha: 就用盒马的袋子就行
Tasha: Just use the Hema bag.
Alice:用这个吧
Alice: Let's use this one.
Tasha: 上才艺
Tasha: Let's show our talent.
Jake: 这有啥才艺
Jake: What talent do we have?
Tasha: 倒
Tasha: Pour it out.
Tasha: 还好我觉得今天浪费的一点都不多
Tasha: Actually, I think we didn't waste much today.
Jake: 哎呀不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry about that.
Tasha: 这不是不好意思就可以的
Tasha: "Sorry" isn't enough.
Jake: 对不起对不起对不起
Jake: I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:私密马赛
Alice: Sumimasen (Excuse me in Japanese).
Jake: 我先放地上吧
Jake: I'll just put it on the floor.
Jake: 可以吗
Jake: Is that okay?
Tasha: 放呀
Tasha: Put it down.
Jake: 我也没有别的地方放
Jake: I have nowhere else to put it.
Jake: 或者放那边桌上
Jake: Or put it on the table over there.
Jake: 放我桌上
Jake: Put it on my table.
Jake: 喔这个竟然
Jake: Oh, this actually...
Jake:你们竟然有火烤
Jake: You guys actually have a grill.
Alice: 难道我要别在我的腰上
Alice: Do I have to tie it around my waist?